almost all american journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the new stories we
consume every day
and it's completely free to use go to
news voice dot com
slash pacman to download it
there is now an extensive series of
disgusting but not altogether surprising
allegations that donald trump is
essentially laundering money through his
campaign
and then making potentially illegal
secret payments
including to his own family with that
campaign cash
hiding the recipients through
um organizations llcs
businesses and agencies and it turns out
that
hundreds of millions of dollars in
spending by trump's campaign
is flowing through two companies with no
disclosure
of how the money has been spent the
nonpartisan campaign legal center is now
accusing the campaign of violating
federal election
transparency rules by shielding the real
source of campaign expenditures and the
recipients now
remember that i mean what does it matter
he lies all the time but when he was
running for president
donald trump claimed that his
administration would be the most
transparent in history
as president donald trump has claimed
his
administration is the most transparent
in history
and obviously that is not the case the
complaint is extremely detailed it says
payments have been masked but made to a
bunch of trump's family members
including
people like eric trump's wife lara trump
who doubles as campaign staff
conveniently
don jr's girlfriend kimberly guilfoyle
on the mend from
coronavirus i think also doubling his
campaigns it's not just don's girlfriend
it's also a campaign advisor
they also do a lot of their ad buys
through a company called
american-made media consultants and
through a private company owned by
none other than donald trump's former
campaign manager brad parscale
understand like the incestuous nature of
this
until he got demoted brad parscale was
running trump's campaign
and directing ad spending for trump's
campaign
and a lot of the spending was brokered
and
filtered through the company that brad
parscale
owns it's genius right i mean what a
great way to line your own pockets
american-made media consultants is a
company
that the trump campaign itself controls
meaning
once the payments go from the trump
campaign to american-made media
consultants
they go to whoever trump wants with no
transparency
tens of millions of dollars by the way
have been run through brad parscale's
company
and don jr's girlfriend is getting paid
15 000 a month 180 grand a year for
working on the trump campaign
same thing with lara trump eric trump's
girlfriend
brad parscale has acknowledged that he's
paying them saying quote
i can pay them however i want to pay
them
now you probably can understand the way
in which this is a useful method for
funneling money to your friends and
family and of course
the legal case before the fec it's going
to be litigated for a long time
we likely won't know the outcome until
after the november election certainly i
would i would bet
but there should be no surprise
whatsoever
that they are doing this because this is
how they operate
donald trump has been doing this his
entire presidency trump has been
funneling money
through his golf clubs back into his
family's pockets understand that trump
at last count had golf 282 days so far
this
uh presidency when he overwhelmingly
that's his
at his own golf clubs when he goes to
his own golf clubs particularly when he
spends the night
secret service and white house staff all
rent rooms at his golf club secret
service rents
you know dozens of golf carts and they
pay
trump's clubs for that that money of
course goes right back
to trump and to his family this is
trump's entire life this is how trump
has done business
in real estate in new york city and
around the world forever and you know
there was actually a time
where there would be consequences for
this type of thing in the united states
remember former president jimmy carter
jimmy carter's family had a peanut farm
in georgia
and jimmy carter separated himself
from the peanut farm so that he couldn't
conceivably be seen
as acting in a way that was favorable to
his family's business like imagine that
he were to push for certain
laws related to farming that could be
seen as favoritism
to his own family's business it almost
seems
quaint and provincial that that's what
he did
given what donald trump is doing now
with absolutely no repercussions
whatsoever this is the type of thing
donald trump did his entire life
uh and it should come as no surprise
whatsoever that he's continuing to do it
the only question is is he gonna get
another four years to do it
if your weight you know as i've said
before if you're waiting for trump to
end up in prison
it's not going to happen if you're
waiting for trump to be carried out you
know
uh let out in hand it's not going to
happen the opportunity is
we stop this and he only gets four years
he could get
another four years to do this stuff and
by the way
do his donors care like if you're a
donor and you donated a hundred bucks to
trump
and you find out 90 of it went to brad
parscale's company
and parscale kept 20 and then he gave 20
to don junior's girlfriend
and he gave 20 to eric trump's wife lara
trump like
if you donated a hundred bucks and only
10 is actually used for an ad buy
are you okay with that are you furious
or if you're presented with this do you
just deny the reality and say it's fake
news like
please if you're a trumpist in my
audience and i know i have
some um doesn't this bother you
doesn't this just lining everybody's
pockets
uh bother you or do you just not believe
that this is going on i want to hear
from you
and we'll continue covering this on the
david pakman show instagram page
at david pakman show we will take a
quick break and be back after this